Hey youtubers it’s Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to re-watch the
doctor who premiere a few times.
In my review I asked you to submit questions
so we’ll try to answer some of the big ones.
I think the biggest types of questions were
Missy related and the the big changes.
There are a few important things that I’m
going to mention after all the question but
let’s talk about the episode first.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go
Question 1 - amazedsatsuma asks Could Missy
be Mercy Hartigan from The Next Doctor Special?
There were so many Missy theories that I’ll
see if I can sum them all up in this one question,
so this will go on a little bit longer than
the other questions.
There are a few things we know about the finale.
It involves Missy and the Cybermen and Heaven.
The title of the final episode is Death in
Heaven.
There were a lot of suggestions you guys all
had in the comments.
Mercy was one of them, as was Susan Foreman
the Doctor’s Granddaughter, Romana, The
Rani, Tasha Lem, A Female Master or Mistress
I guess you’d call her, because she’s
a woman.
And another personification of the TARDIS,
like in The Doctor’s Wife episode.
Some of you guys actually wrote some really
well thought out theories.
Right now my favorites are Susan Foreman and
a female Master.
Another commenter Zachary had a really good
explanation for the Susan theory.
First, the doctor left her in the far future
and promised to come back.
But he never did.
Remember how I said the Doctor leaving people
behind was a recurring theme in Deep Breath.
As well as The Girl who Waited.
It’s possible that Missy is a future version
of Susan, but it requires that some rules
get bent on the resort planet from that Amy
Pond episode.
The disease there killed people with two hearts,
so Susan would technically die if Paradise
was that same planet.
I don’t think that’s the case, I think
Missy is in a pocket universe.
The Nethersphere.
I think she’s called the gatekeeper just
because she controls access.
If you look at Moffat’s quote about the
finale too, remember the doctor made a promise
to susan.
The synopsis reads.
"You betrayed me.
You betrayed my trust, our friendship, and
everything I've ever stood for.
You let me down."
- that could be a lot of people saying that
though.
The next best theory is Rani.
I don’t remember, but she might have been
stuck in a pocket universe at some point.
She did have a lot of stories involving dinosaurs.
Supposedly in the novels she had her head
cut off though.
Plus, I don’t think the Rani ever had the
sexualized obsession with the doctor Missy
seems to have.
Then there’s The Female Master.
Mistress is certainly a play on that.
And you could say that the doctor and the
master have shared a very co-dependent relationship.
Moffat said that The Master was dead and gone,
but it could be a Moffat lies situation where
yes, the Master is gone, but only because
he’s The Mistress now.
Viewing that as a different character.
Then there’s Tasha Lem, who could have found
a way to change herself to fix the Dalek assimilation.
She and the Doctor had a sexual relationship
at one point.
But the vibe I got from Missy was so sinister
that I don’t think it was Tasha.
The
TARDIS theories all stem from the use of the
word Sexy, like Missy could be some of the
essence of The TARDIS in female form.
She also refers to the Doctor’s new accent
and says “I’ll keep it”.
Remember that the TARDIS said she originally
stole the Doctor, the Doctor didn’t steal
her.
On top of all that, if you look at the brooches
both Clara and Missy were wearing.
Clara’s looked like the untempered schism
and Missy’s reminded me of the Lady in White.
So I guess you could add Lady in White to
the list of possibilities.
Although she seems more like the Doctor’s
mother.
Not his girlfriend.
So best three theories right now are Susan,
TARDIS Essence and The Mistress.
Question 2 - Vicram Films asks Did you notice
that he told the robot that you have changed
your parts so many times, that there is no
trace of you left?
Was that also a reference to himself?
He has changed so many times that there is
no trace of his original self left?
Good question, yes he was totally talking
to himself as much as the Robot.
Moffat said a long time ago that the Doctor
would regenerate past his limit but that there
would be consequences.
Now we know that the Time Lords gave him a
new cycle, which harkens back to Deadly Assassin,
when the Master tried to steal a new cycle.
I think there are still original aspects of
his first self inside there.
I think it just takes him longer to find them
in his mind palace.
He keeps having trouble remembering things.
I think that as he continues to regenerate
it will get worse.
That whole exchange is seeding a big plot
for series 8.
The doctor remembering his face and correcting
mistakes of the past will be big recurring
themes.
Question 3 - James Swift do you think that
the fires of Pompeii Capaldi is The Doctor
in human form using the pocket watch?
Good Pocketwatch question.
No I don’t think so.
I think some of his familiar face talk was
acknowledging the meta thing happening.
But I don’t think fires of pompeii capaldi
will go further than that.
I don’t think it’s some big major thing.
I think someone else in the comments pointed
out that Colin Baker guest starred on Doctor
Who before becoming the Doctor.
So it’s happened before.
Koglin JV actually pointed out that the 'tramp'
the doctor supposedly gave the watch to is
actually Elizabeth Sladen's real life husband.
Question 4 - Nayef asks Hey charlie, does
the doctor choice, how he look when regenerate
or same else,choice for him.
The Doctor can influence regenerations under
certain conditions.
The Master is the only Time Lord that has
complete control over his appearance regardless
of circumstance.
The Sisterhood of the Karn have an elixir
that can control regenerations.
During The Night of the Doctor Paul McGann
regenerates into John Hurt specifically choosing
to become more of a warrior.
Usually it’s just a measure of skill, but
there’s still a degree of chance involved.
It’s possible for a forced regeneration
to result in disfigurement.
But I think they only get into that in the
novels.
As the series has gone on, the producers have
added layers of complexity to the science
of regeneration.
So presumably Moffat will explain what some
of the consequences of going beyond 12 are.
There’s a really old explanation that Rassilon
imposed the rule of 12 for a specific reason
but I couldn’t find a satisfactory answer
other than it wasn’t punitive.
He wasn’t punishing the Time Lords by imposing
the limit of 12.
Question 5 - Shelley Summers asks What’s
the big deal with the Doctor giving the man
his watch?
The doctor can store his time lord essence
in it.
All his memories and his regenerations.
They’re using the pocketwatch titles now,
so I don’t know if that’s going to tie
in with the Doctor’s actual pocketwatch
or if it’s just a coincidence.
Not everything that Moffat does is about foreshadowing.
Originally when he wrote River Song into the
series during David Tennant’s run, he didn’t
know that he’d use her as Amy and Rory’s
daughter when he took over the series.
And the Master’s pocketwatch was something
Russell Davies did.
I don’t know that they’d do something
similar so soon.
But the watch itself is just an infamous piece
of Time Lord technology.
Question 6- Sushant mentions what about the
Doctor’s Ring that we got a good look at
after the phonecall
Okay, thank you for mentioning this, I forgot
to include it in my review.
The Ring is going to be part of the story
in Series 8.
The first Doctor wore a blue signet ring that
had some special abilities.
The Seventh Doctor later found it and started
wearing it again.
It also belonged to The Other at one point.
The Other was one of the founders of the Time
Lord’s Society along with Rassilon and Omega.
There was a bit of an easter egg during the
episode where the Robot Leader asks Clara
where the “Other” is.
He never calls Capaldi the Doctor, he calls
him “The Other”.
Supposedly, The Other tried to escape Gallifrey
when Rassilon started to consolidate his power.
He entered the Looms, which were the devices
the Time Lords used to procreate.
The Looms weaved genetic material together
to create new children.
Further rumors, The Other was reconstituted
10 Million years later as the First Doctor.
That story was from the novels.
Not the regular series.
I guess you can take the validity of that
claim based on how much you think the novels
are canon.
That doesn’t mean The Doctor is secretly
The Other, I think it’s just the writers
winking at us.
If they included a joke about the Scottish
referendum, than you can bet there are plenty
of more obscure references throughout.
Some of them are visual, like the Brooches
Missy and Clara wore and some are verbal.
Question 7 - ApolloNik asks What do you think
the writing in chalk all over the bedroom
was all about?
I think that’s Capaldi’s cracks in the
universe.
I think that he will find gallifrey at some
point this series.
It’s currently in a pocket universe.
And the equations will have something to do
with getting there.
I also think they’ll tie in with the Missy
plot and the Nethersphere.
I also think the Nethersphere has something
to do with the pocket universe.
and Question 8 - Louie asks now Capaldi is
an older doctor will he start to get slightly
older companions?
or will we start to see old enemies such as
the zygons return?
They did say revisiting old faces.
And the synopsis for the finale says that
old enemies return.
As to which old faces are returning I have
no idea.
But you can reference my favorite Missy theories.
We did see all the cybermen pictures.
And the Daleks are back.
Like the doctor said in the episode, I’ve
seen this before.
My hope is that they use all these familiar
things in new and interesting ways.
But everybody will have their own opinion
on that.
Thanks so much for submitting questions everyone.
It’s going to be a lot of fun talking about
doctor who with you guys this series.
I’ll always wait a day after posting review
to post Q&As just to give people time to watch
the episode.
And Congratulations to the winners of this
week’s giveaway.
smalley mcsmall & Rosie Howe.
Usually there’s just one weekly winner but
I’m so happy Doctor Who is back I’m doubling
it.
You guys both win amazon gift cards.
I’ll message you on your channels for details.
I also wanted to thank everyone for being
so polite in the comments.
I knew there would be a lot of extreme opinions
because of all the big changes but all of
you did a great job of explaining why you
didn’t like things without personally attacking
moffat.
There was a really awesome gif I posted that
summed up a lot of feelings in a really simple
way.
I’m working on a game of thrones video for
tomorrow.
My next doctor who video will be saturday
morning before episode 2 airs, and I’ll
post my review after the episode.
Moffat explained each of the episodes this
series you can click here to learn what he
said.
And you can click here for my episode 1 review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives